foreign
[Music]
ah I can't get away from you
when you got a girl I got myself an
enemy cause I need that your attention
like a centipedes
the end of everything we could have been
my broken hearts that let you in I still
see you in my sleep how come I still see
you when I
Dreaming from the truth but it don't
matter
foreign
[Music]
how come I still see you when I am
true but it
thought I do no matter what I do I can't
get away
from you
I came get away from
[Music]
you y'all make some noise for my girl
Heather Ann Crawford please
[Applause]
hello everyone my name is Jesse Reyes
and I'm here because I've made a
profound discovery
were born we grow we die and life is
suffering thank you for coming to my TED
Talk
[Applause]
when we need to eat and we can't we
suffer when we need to breathe and we
can't we suffer
communal beings need to love and when we
can't
we write sad love songs
in March of 2016 I was just getting
started as a songwriter
I was knee-deep in demos and potential
but I had nothing to show for it AKA
broke
and to top it off I was incredibly
heartbroken over someone who had
betrayed me
one night I went into the studio and I
emotionally vomited into the microphone
kind of like what I did here
the song I made that night ended up
changing the course of my life forever
I made figures
it went viral
I got signed I went on tour I made some
bread I officially retired my parents I
made an album
made another album got called by Ted
Talk and now I'm here with you lovely
people
sounds great but I'm not saying my life
is perfect and I obviously still deal
with my fair share of problems however
after that experience I naturally came
to subscribe to the school of thought
that even when we can't see it in the
moment it seems as though the greater
good is always working in our favor
anytime that we connect the dots
backwards
in case you missed the sarcasm in the
beginning I don't think I've made some
profound Discovery but when I was
presented with this opportunity I wanted
to take the chance to almost serve as a
reminder for what seems like the obvious
sometimes
at my shows
near the end of the set I tell this
story and every time I do I always
acknowledge the possibility of there
being a Negative Nancy in the audience
thinking to herself well Jesse I don't
write sad love songs or well Jesse I
don't have faith in the greater good so
what the [__] does this have to do with
me Nancy I'll tell you
it doesn't matter what conduit you use
whether it's music whether it's painting
whether it's a robotic electrical bird
conspiracy it doesn't matter what tool
you use but what's important to remember
is this
the burdens of Life get significantly
lighter when we acknowledge the agency
that we all have in converting a loss to
a win contingent on how we approach and
or capitalize off of the ruins at our
feet
[Music]
a very verbose way of saying life is
what you make it
we're all capable of magic and it just
so happens that my version of this magic
comes by way of turning heartbreak into
songs
hardship
hardship this is a good one are you
ready
a hardship can either be a trojan horse
or the Trojan condom you put on when you
finally say [__] it
my Big Brother's gonna like that one
not saying like do nothing and let go of
the wheel when things go left but when
we employ some faith
while simultaneously working on
self-betterment I think that we can get
to wherever the River of Life was going
regardless of us trying to resist
because there is no escaping it
it seems like the writing's on the wall
life's ah [__]
but I prefer the way that my Colombian
dad pronounces it
life said Beach
the beach
the irony is poetic
so I think sometimes it's better to ride
the wave instead of drowning
my name is Jesse Reyes thank you for
your time and this will be my last song
thank you
figures
[Music]
I gave you a ride to die and you gave me
games love figures
I know I'm crying cause you just won't
change love figures
[Music]
I gave it all and you gave me [__] love
figures
I wish I could do exactly what you did
wish I could hurt you back
[Music]
you're the one of gonna lose
that's the way I wish that I could do to
you you
who
love to you
who figures
I'm the bad guy cause I can't learn to
trust love and figures
[Music]
you say sorry once and you think that's
enough I've got a lineup of girls in a
lineup of guys
[Music]
I'm willing to stay cause I'm sick for
your love
[Music]
[Applause]
I wish I could hurt you bad
[Music]
love what would you do if you couldn't
get me back yo you're the one who's gone
don't lose something so special
something so real tell me boy how in the
[__] would you feel if you couldn't get
me
back that's why I wish that I could do
oh
two
[Music]
oh
thank you
thank you thank you very much